alors que sont laurent ruquier a
ressorti un dossier d'elle quand elle a
fait un pas de danse particulier c'était
le tam-tam qu avec la fouillade
elle a révélé que maintenant elle ne
faisait plus ce geste regardez ça
l'attention quand tendance avec qui on
danse ou à qui on veut apprendre à
danser parce que vous avez été piégé une
fois j'ai refais aux autos si je vous
dis la danse tam tam est ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose
la danse tam-tam j'imagine que c'est le
ta maison tu as voilà c'est ça ça vous
rappelle quelqu'un oui la fouine ça vous
dit quelque chose la foule baisse et ça
n'avait pas porté plainte
rien non non non mais en fait c'est une
figure un peu de lindy hop et j'ai des
copains copains danseurs qu'ils ont faim
qui la faisait dans leur chorégraphie et
j'ai toujours trouvé ça génial parce que
les gens se marrait c'est rigolo quoi
vous n'auriez pas chez nous ce soir mais
je leur ferai plus parce que du coup
c'est vrai que les gens ne comprennent
pas forcément voilà alors et on va on va
rien se tairont 4 en 2014 que fauve
hautot avait fait ce pas de danse dont
les pmp et je peux la comprendre parce
que c'est vrai qu'à des gens après
qu'ils ont critiqué alors que fait
vraiment pas dedans il faisait marrer et
voilà il approuve que j'allais tuer et
c'est un amour et non plus à dans la
leçon est pris plein la gueule à mon
avis sur les réseaux social et journée à
mâcon chômage alors que c'était là les
hyper simple trou et se régaler de
hockey maintenant je descends à wil a
claqué battant
[Applaudissements]
usa
il s'envolera pour ce faire
arrêtez d'écouter le diktat de la
bienséance et ça qui vous expliquent
toute la longueur de journée le bien le
mal là il va y avoir quatre hystérique
qui vont écrire hostas en disant voilà
mon dieu c'est affreux mais qu'elle
réclame mêmes même latéral droit alors
fait beaucoup laurent ruquier mais la
question noire qui venait volant il
s'est pris au jeu il l'a fait en
rigolant ça se voit qu'il n'ya pas
manquer de respect excellent mélanome et
non pas patron laurent ruquier supply
chain vous plaît quand laurent ruquier
lui dit et je laime franchement ils
l'aiment bien en plaine la mer roquet
continue d'y mener pas non mais les
tarifs mais pas porter plainte comme
souris n'est pas porté
il est arrivé que j'adore kezman et
jeudi jours avant il fait une blague sur
sur la mise pour concevoir le dessus bon
ben voilà c'est vrai il emmènera non
mais voilà laurent là il est fou de
poser une question comme ça à mon avis
la justice et clichy venez y découvrir
les missions comme moi ouais voilà pas
le faire ça laurent faut pas le faire
dans danse avec les stars elle l'a fait
avec les stars qu'elles avaient sprayé
vous la fais retard et samer hanna on
n'avait pas inventé mais vous croyez
vraiment je suis un chorégraphe moi je
pense au tam-tam qqq alan tam tam ou au
dessus on le voit